[Music]
do you mind if I bring the camera
Ginger's Huw night for a good cause
Prince Harry and ed sheeran teamed up
for World Mental Health Day releasing a
pretty funny PSA on Thursday funny
because well we'll just let you watch
this for me is a subject of conversation
it's just not talked about enough I
think people all over the world are
really suffering people just don't
understand that it's life people ask
yeah well you know the jokes and the
snide comments and you know I just feel
like it's time we stood up and said you
know we're not gonna take this anymore
weird ginger oh yeah yeah yeah yeah ed
miss understood the assignment I know
we're good yeah okay guys this world
mental health day reach out make sure
that your friends strangers look out for
anybody that might be suffering in
science and we're all in this together
ah gotta love those two and got a love
that we know what Harry and Megan's
doorbell sounds like
[Music]
yeahit's god save the queen aka harry's
grandma amazing anyway apparently this
was pretty much Harry and Ed's first
time really meeting doc met Harry once
right
what's your enough yeah but that was
like in 2011 at his grands Jubilee okay
and it was like hey hey we're glad these
two finally had a proper hang and for
such a great reason mental health
awareness is a passion project for Harry
and his family in 2016 Harry his brother
william and william's wife kate launched
the heads together movement to change
the conversation the idea was to get
people talking about mental health by
sharing their own struggles if our
experiences was sharing those
experiences can help reduce the stigma
for the rest of the UK then that's where
the jeolla-do team service that comes in
and this isn't the first time the Royals
have teamed up with a superstar to shine
a light on the cause in 2017 william
facetimed with lady gaga there's a lot
of shame attached to mental illness you
feel like something's wrong with you and
in my life I go oh my goodness look at
all these beautiful wonderful things
that I have and I should be so happy but
you can't help it if in the morning when
you wake up you are so tired you are so
sad you are so full of anxiety and the
shakes that you can barely think but it
was like saying this is a part of me and
that's okay just all the feels will
leave you with Harry's message that came
along with a vid with Ed quote there's
no need to suffer in silence share how
you're feeling
ask us someone is doing and listen for
the answer be willing to ask for help
when you need it and know that we are
all in this together
hashtag wmh d so go ask someone how
they're doing and have a good real chat
about life that'll do it for now I'm
Katie Krauss and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]